BETT TASK THANETINS MEOW.
BY THE WAYE'NECALLED "PINKI."
>>AR EOPLE ARE SUDDENLGAINTH
ANR  TE,
BEEN TAL
POPULAR ACROSS THEUT, IT'S
LY BOTH HALVES
I TAEDBOUT THEH TAX INDIVIDUALS
AND M CORPORATE TAX, K PROFITS
YOU KNOWAMIONS.
RD $10 BIL
AROUNNOTHING ES.TAX
E BENG E S INTO
CKAGE.
NEE IT INTO THE
YOU OW I THIS?AN PEOEY UNDERSTAO
WE, THISA OFG
BILLIONAIR OEI
, QUOTE, EVENTUALLY, TY OUT OF F
INUN SENATE  IZ WARREN
YOU SAY,THATS YOUR COMMEN? T 9 .
LIVES, THEY .2%. LESS THAN HALAG
SAME R
ELUSD HIS KIND COULD
NEED IN ICA.
UNIVERSAL CHILCA
NITY-BASEDH CAREND
INVESTMENTS IN HSIK IN F
SEE CHE , THEYE  FREE LOADG  LEI
THEN I'LL HAVE A FOLLOUP
ROLL IT.
SE.>> THERE IDYN THIS
YOU BUILT FATH YOUANE  YOU E RO
YOU HIREWORKT OF
US PAID .E IN YOUFA
SEIZE SOMEONE INR FACTD
ANOMEONEO PROTEC
AG BECOF US
LOOK LIOUG >> TALANDIDATE FOR
SE Q., AND I EL
IT I STILL FEEABOUT K, YBAZILLIO
LLOOD FOU.
DO MIND, THE REST OF A
CEAR HAVE THATOULD
CKO THIS- PAY THEIR S THQUESTIOY
PRINCIPLE OUOSOPHY?
HE CONSTRA
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENTINALL PRE
THEY'RCOMING
DON'T WHAT HE'S SAY TAX EVERYBOJ
I BELIEVXATIONRESSIVE.THOS TOP T
TO BE PAYING NT S BUT ACTULY LI
F Y'VE
CHING ITN SO
THE NEXTIO A
AND THE NEXT GENERATION AFTER
ATAND TH GENERATIOR
THAT.
FAMILIESOS A
ING.
TH WDOONRIHEACS A MUCH SMALL.
>>S POSSIBLAX THE
F TH AMOI ME YOU D
WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH SOMEONW
WHO HA GAI
BY WHAXT YEAR EYD E GOVERNMENT O
SS
SN -- LET'S
STT HE FACT THAT0% O
THE WEALTH
TN
SECURITIES SO,, THAT ONE
EASY TO VA
IT'S ALREADY VALD EVERY YEAR.NGA
THE VALUATION .SON THROUGH THAS
OF
SO, ITKS F.RA YEAR,
HE
REMBRANDISR T LEASLE
Y OR SART. SMALL
PEOPLE.
ITYEY
THIS IS THE CAPUT THE IR
PEOP SCIION. MAK HAPPEN ANEQNC
CHILDREN.
WEAVY TO.
S ANIDGEAROUND US.OP GL
Y I CAGOAUCH
CAREAKE TH AND
ONCE A A RICHER.
IFORN AND RENTS,
DADD
I WANTNVEANSATE IN WCE RAISEP F
O THAT PAY
TELL ME QUICKLBO PROMIS" WMP T
S ING FOR RAOF TS.LL T TNG
SO, K FO GIRLS I
NE F
WAS MY FOFHE L